zwei leute oder so zwei gleichstarke
teams treffen alle hier sind team
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer pvp arena
kampf battle zusammen mit ungespielt in
der unkomplizierte auf dem komma hd
server bei mir ohne akku alle ist
demnächst wieder und wir haben einfach
hier ein paar diamant sachen ausgerüstet
bekommen und kämpfen jetzt einfach gegen
du bist du wo bist du
ich bin auf dem schiff oben verrät ich
habe gerade ein getötet conny und ich
nehme auch als wasserwerker alter alle
gegen alle
wie macht also gleich einfach drauf aber
verzieht euch mal wenn ich jetzt sterben
sterben nämlich nicht aus sie wissen
schon am also kurz bis mal alle
verteilen ist sinnlos anfang antrieb all
das ist der pvp ist ein kleiner see
jeder-gegen-jeden ist ja aber ich hab
das ist aber wenn das ist einfach nur
mal dass man andere drauf haben
anstatt dass man mit gar nix starteten
sich dann eigentlich einfach kids
besuchen wird
aber wir sind ja dann frage ich mich ja
auch das ist einfach nur windows drauf
umschlagen
ok gedacht es gäbe hier vielleicht ein
sind sie meinte dass wertvolle
interessant die so echt
das ist einfach geschlagen
okay wir kämpfen uns jetzt einfach und
ist frei ja ich bin auch wieder thomas
muss auch essen ist dann kostet es mehr
dann ist man ja sowieso oft ausgeliefert
dem tode
wo bist du und im schiff am kronleuchter
noch vor so leuten weg mann mann mann
stirbt wieder wenn du stimmst du direkt
wieder mit einem gleichen sachen wo bist
du denn ich bin auf seinen sprung auf
neun bis dahin genau ob ich habe einfach
niemanden gehauen
ich bin oben da wo man nur da wo man
wieder belebt egal ich habe einfach kein
pazifist mal gucken ob ich mich einfach
tritt eine politik zu nehmen
ich möchte hier sehr jeder gegen jeden
fall werde ich wahrscheinlich schon
ich bin der friedliche öko ich möchte
einfach nur hier wohne ich drehe jetzt
erste abschnitt ich lenkt uns ich fahr
uns zur karibik
ob es denn um am steuerrad versteckt im
raum bekommen wir nicht öffnen aber ja
mitunter steuer hat es so schwer fällt
das zu sehen
ok am steuer bitte komm ich habe mich
wie viel leben noch zwei wir setzen
nicht mehr weil ich hab hunger
ich bin auf dem weg am steuerrad hier
wegpacken anna oben bisher aber darum
sind die ganzen anderen komm wir gehen
wie titanic
ich bin der könig der welt
ja ich werde geschlagen boxen ist ja
verdammt wenig oben achtest du gar nicht
wollte doch das war ich ich wollte sich
retten
aber das was du nicht retten wollte
hier sind so viele leute irgendwie
sinnlos für dich weil mit diamant ist
einfach sinnlos dass man die ammann
schwert oder man trifft 100 es für
besser wenn ich nicht wieso wird nur
geschlagen schützen wiederum geputzte
herunter mit dir ich kann dir was
schreiben oder dass wir geschlagen
da hat sich etwas ganz innovatives
einfach das hat einfach alle die
gleichen sachen kommen jetzt schlagen
oder es kein essen gibt
ich habe heimlich gefunden
conny vielleicht sollten wir das ziel
setzen besonders zusammen lage zu machen
leute lasst uns fangen spielen
mein mann verstecken wir richtig killer
wer findet mich okay ich hab mich
versteckt aber am arsch der welt
denn auch davor besteht nicht sie
schlagen sich dauernd gerade vom heilen
ist das schwert kaputt conny die mega
geheim weg gefunden
ja und ich musste die halle
ja man wo bist du denn unterm schiff
ganz unten
okay ich bin unten in der luft als sich
alle im falle von vacha okay okay das
ist guter geheim weg du ja jetzt muss
ich überleben
heute ein halbes herz gehabt jetzt die
haupt links runter zum riesen raum unter
dem schiff ist hinter mir wünsche
schlauer
ja ich glaub auch bauermann
wenn diese leute die an dieses nicht
akzeptieren sondern server vorstellen
bei der frist sollte sowas sagen ja es
gibt hier zwei games und es gibt ja
weiter ist doof wenn wir das jetzt
mitten im video machen weil dann
schreiben wir das im titel und dann
sehen dass leute dann irgendwie voran
machen
das machen wir dann anders man uns was
der server domradio.de hab ich jetzt mal
gesagt und das ist sehr cool
wir wollten mal vielleicht da auf dem
skywalk mal unseres eines klar wir
wollten unser eigenes blog wir machen da
könnt ihr einfach meinen daumen hoch
geben wenn ihr auch so was wollt aber
das hier ist ein remake sinnlos dass
hier da dachten wir zunehmend kommen
anfangs nicht mit skype blog an so
spontan wie machen wir wieder hier so
was geiles und pick ups und vertrautes
wert gehabt computer ist natürlich allen
pnp
wir werden wahrscheinlich dass kein blog
haben wollt also schreibt seine hinweise
gibt einfach das einfacher und dann
werden wir uns das mal anschauen ob das
eine große breite begeisterung
reformieren
nicht gut weg von mir ich bin ganz oben
auf dem schiff was drauf ganz oben simon
da beim spawn punkt nicht stellt euch
mal vor dem fest ankommt nach oben alpha
brennt wo bist du denn
ja ich bin ja soll ich damit einfach
runter springt von dem thema hat jetzt
werde ich so genannten 80 auf den
pfeiler ich bin es runter von rechts und
links schläger simon ja ich bin doch
geschlagen worden
ich springe hat in den sportbereich ich
springe der springmaus bonn achtet nach
oben zu stellen kommt man an die
autotage weg das ziel ist ein fest lexus
wird von dem von dem admin bockhorn
entwickler wir können alles richtig
wegschlagen
da fliegen die einfach drauflos
wer sein und hat gesagt wir machen das
hier weil es den computerfehler der pvp
sein aber irgendwie muss ich dann so was
sind uns drauf klappe es gefällt nicht
irgendwie keine ahnung wo ist denn der
spaß hier bei ihr könnt ihr meine
kommentare schreiben was man verbessern
könnte das wird vielleicht auch helfen
weil dann wird man vielleicht sachen
verbessern was hier was wir verbessern
können mit viel spaß macht also kern des
halt alle mit 0 sachen staaten nur mit
holz werden dass in den ganzen kiste
sachen verteilt sind aber in jeder kiste
sind halt immer so die gleichen sachen
drin und auch unendlich viele also dass
wenn jeder rein guckt das dann ja was
hast du willst dann die leute dann
ruhige farben werden die leute die mich
stellt keinen klub kommt zuerst oben
also ich finde persönlich liegt vor mir
sah ich eine krisenphase bekommt man
dass man seine sachen finden muss als
der gips mit sicherheit paar gute gründe
wie sie jetzt ist das einfach alle
diamanten bekommen betroffen
kommunikativ grundfutter nein ich komm
hoch und alle schlagen mich ach ich hab
mich wäre das besser machen als ob das
wirklich
ja ja letztlich tot gewesen
ich habe versucht schnell wieder schnell
archiv rhein runter unterschied ist es
eine kammer raum nummer 9
da konnte wenn er reinkommt
nahezu frieden hier nur daher gibt nicht
verbrennen ableiten dass wir das jetzt
hier aufgemacht tut mir leid ich bin
hier oben runter mussten auf dem schiff
am steuer mensch am steuer dagegen
steuerkompromiss sicher durchzukommen
okay was ist das wasserspiel nur dürftig
ihr könnt ihr einfach wirklich quartal
stellen wenn dir so ein spielmodus hier
spielt was wünscht ihr euch für so ein
spiel ist also ein wo man einfach nur
knüppel muss wollte wollte er auch nicht
besonderen extra zwei kommen kannst ja
selber einstehen so hoch du hast
kontrast verschont deswegen zu stärken
was sie so alles hochkommt hinten los
zieht auch die leiter auf die eltern und
alle die zu hoch kommen und schon wieder
hat schulz war erst kürzlich
sofortschutz sie so voll der ask 78 ja
unser buch
beispiel sagen gestoppt dass er gleich
weil junge zu langweilig für die
zuschauer war das ein hochgekommen sich
also wieder rauszukommen
lasst mich durchgriff auf alle drauf
dienstag in dresden
max kollidiert
na ja also ich muss natürlich sagen ich
finde das langweilig du wolltest spielen
ich wollte dich festspielen war stand
pvp arena ich hab das ja so was wie
arena besser zwischen arena ist zwei
leute oder so zwei gleichstarke teams
treffen einander und wieder alle hier
sind teenager mit infleet also das war's
zu haben weiß aber dass die politik also
ist dieses auf ihre aufgabe ist aber
diesmal muss ist aber lief also wir sind
hier in dieser premium lobby du
vielleicht wundern harnik spielt also
dass die premium member aria und hier
gibt es dieses untersteht hat pvp arena
ich dachte mir so nah die stars arena
voll spannend aber irgendwie naja war
nicht so aber hier in kurzer zeit des
plädoyers hatte ein blog erst mal das
kann mich auch ein ganz gefangen dann
wird euch dann einfach eure inseln
einmal wir haben es jetzt schon intern
erstellte eine insel schiffe anbrennen
ja aber und kanada wie das setup
vielleicht rom
ich bin auch mal insel das insel die
sich nach vorne sie gar nicht da sie als
am wasser und so und hier kommt zu mir
besuche ich weiß besuch hier machen
leute besuchen weiß wie habt ihr
gesendet ich weiß nicht wie es geht
axept oder so wird war besitzt
tt.com ganz viele menschen viele
angenommen
nein das sind einfach alle leute ja da
das ist simons rastete box nicht ist
aber zwei bäume
ich sehe überhaupt nichts will komisch
naja egal
beim gehört einfach in die kommentare
schreiben wenn ihr's ken block haben
wollt wird also so dass man halt mit
einer leuten hier zusammen über darunter
um inseln und man muss sich dann findet
man kann die seine insel ausbauen
verlust ich auf jeden fall das pvp arena
ging das gefällt mir nicht so gut weil
herr willis cop ist aber hier dieses kai
bergmann lust drauf dass über so ein
bisschen längeren zeitraum zu machen
vielleicht also vielleicht eine woche
lang und gucken was dabei rauskommt so
als kleines mini projekt oder so wäre
ich ja ganz coole sache also ja nächste
woche gibt es das vielleicht entstand
und konnten später fischer gibt
schlechte die und kork oder irgendwie
sowas will ich etwas sagen wenn es euch
gefallen hat positive bewertung abgeben
könnt ihr in die kommentare schreiben
was ihr davon haltet von ihren
spielprinzipien und so und dann eine
info geben ich bin von heute morgen ab
bei meinem freund bis sonntag das heißt
es kommen die nächste ein video pro tag
nur damit bescheid wisst ja also könnt
ihr noch einmal um hält nicht versuchen
nur einmal helton pro tag und konnte
zweimal wahrscheinlich wieder doch weil
bei mir kommt es wahrscheinlich wieder
mehr videos wegen phase vorbei ich bin
ganz unten wasserfall ganz okay man
natürlich sagen
bis zum nächsten
bis zum nächsten video und bauleute